The joe rogan experience.
What do you say to someone who is happy
with what they do lives a fulfilled life
exercises and is still depressed?
Yes. I thought a lot about this,
but remind me to come back to the thing
about east London. I know this is,
this is an issue with a
lot of people. I, yeah,
I know people that worship at the altar
of science and modern medicine that
firmly believe that all depression is
because of some sort of chemical imbalance
in the brain in anything that debates
that are anything that disputes that
notion is, is pisses them off.
Yeah. No, I understand that.
And I would've been like that for me.
That, yeah, of course I was looking at,
I met him in a year. Do you get
that? Some people responded.
Sure, of course. Of course. I think the,
so the World Health Organization is the
leading medical body in the world, right?
They did a survey study of all the best
evidence and they explained very clearly
that the mental health, um,
is a social indicator, right?
It has social causes that need social
solutions as well as individual solutions.
The science of this is overwhelming. You
won't get many scientists who say, uh,
in fact, it'd be struggled to find any
scientists who say depression is purely a
biological phenomenon.
Right?
Pretty much everyone agrees there's
some social and psychological component.
I think when we,
this weird disconnect between what the
scientists know and what the public is
told, right? I don't know anyone
who went to their doctor who, um,
apart from this wonderful doctor in east
London and we can talk about who went
with depression.
I,
that he was told anything other than
a biological story I'm in there,
may be asked, you know, some of them
were asked about childhood, you know,
what was your childhood like?
And referred to a therapist,
but no one was talking about these wider
social causes. No one started like,
do you feel controlled
at work? Well, like I,
it's a fact that could be
making you make you depressed,
but in terms of the people who, who,
um, who are depressed but don't,
uh, cause there was a mystery to
me. Right? I knew people, I thought,
but this guy has got everything
and he feels he's still depressed.
What's going on here? I think
there's two things to say about that.
One is I started to, for various
reasons for research for something else,
I was reading some like feminist
texts from the early sixties right?
And a really common thing that happened
in the early sixties is women would go
to their doctor and they'd say,
doctor,
there's something really
wrong with my nerves,
people to talk about in terms of nerves.
Then we don't do that anymore. Uh,
something really wrong with my nerds
because I've got everything a woman could
possibly want. I've got a husband
who doesn't beat me. I've got a car,
got a washing machine, I've got two
kids, but I feel like shit. Right?
And the doctor would go, you're
right, and give a value. Now,
if we could travel back in time and speak
to those women, what we'd say is right.
You've got everything you could possibly
want by the standards of the culture.
But Stan is the cultural,
just wrong, right? As a w as
a woman, as a human being,
you need more than just a
washing machine and a car. Right?
You need a fulfilling life
of meaning and purpose.
And a very similar thing I
think is happening today if
you, so if you don't want,
I speak to people who say
I've got everything I could
want but I feel like share.
So tell me,
tell me about your life.
Very often they're working really hard
in prestigious jobs that they don't like.
They don't enjoy hour by hour to buy
things that don't give them pleasure.
It comes back to this hijacking junk
values that we're talking about.
The professor Tim Kasser discovered.
So what you've got is because we've been
told a totally misleading story about
what makes us satisfied
and happy as human beings.
I think it comes up again and
again in the interviews you do,
cause we'd been taught in different ways
because we've been told them misleading
story about that we live our lives
according to the wrong script.
We feel like shit.
And rather than question the script,
we think there must be something
wrong with us biologically.
Now there are biological contributions.
It's supported to say that,
but one of things that really blew my
mind on this was um, Ainsley this woman,
amazing social scientists could
not to Bretford in Berkeley,
she did this research. It's kind of
simple research. It just asked. Um,
if you consciously decided you were
going to spend more hours a day trying to
make yourself happier, would you
actually become happier? Right.
And they did this research.
She didn't do a loan obviously with our
colleagues in the United States, Japan,
Russia,
and Taiwan.
And what they found was in the u s
if you try to make yourself happier
consciously, you do not become
happier in the other countries.
If you try to make yourself happier, you
do become happier. And they were like,
what's going on?
So they did more research.
And what they discovered was in the
u s and I spent a lot more time here,
but in Britain as well,
if you try to make yourself happier,
you try to do something generally for
yourself, you buy something for yourself.
Your biggest self,
our PA tried to get a promotion and the
other countries generally if you try to
make yourself happy or you do
something for someone else, right?
You try to help your friends, your family,
your community. Where, what countries?
Just Japan, Russia and China is most
of the really stress this, that if you,
this is a part of their culture
that if you want to be happy,
you do something for
someone else. It's, it's,
it's so implicit in the culture that
they live collectively that it's not even
just like we wouldn't even if you said,
do you think happiness is an
individualistic thing? We'd be like,
what are you even talking about? Isn't
that sort of an extrinsic idea as well?
The idea that you're going to be happy
by trying to make other people happy,
but this is a thing. So intrinsic values
are not about just internal to yourself,
the things that you value.
So your intrinsic value could be
spending time with your kids, right.
That was probably most people strongest
intrinsic value if their parents is
being with their kids,
bonding with their kids.
A lot of my point is if your goal is to
get happy and the way you've chosen to
get happy is I'm going to get happy
by making other people happy. That's,
that seems very strange. I don't think
so. If you think about where humans are.
Dot. Shouldn't you just make other
people happy because you love them.
But that is a way of loving people
and being present with them is a way,
but not as like a specific for with a
specific goal of making yourself happy.
That seems, that's not why they do
it. It's not like when they were told,
make yourself happy. They had an implicit
script in their culture, which is like,
all right,
if I want to make myself happy,
I'll spend time with other people
or do things with other people.
But if you think about it in terms of
human evolution, it makes total sense,
right? I think about our
ancestors where they evolved.
If you were in, uh, a gripper,
if our ancestors had been individually
who were out to big up themselves as
individuals, we wouldn't be
having this conversation.
Right? Right. So it makes us,
we evolved as a species with instincts.
The argument there,
the motivation of trying to get
happy by helping other people.
It just seems be some implicit in the
culture for most people in say China that
they wouldn't even articulate it that way.
It's only if you force them to say,
look, try to make yourself happier that
they, then the script becomes obvious.
It's implicit,
but this script that we have,
this idea that the way you make yourself
happier is as an individual, you know,
just doing something for yourself and
how you hold because there is not one
script and this country of
how to make yourself happy.
I think that's some sort of disingenuous
as I did at the only way to make
yourself happy is to do that. What?
That's not what people are trying to do.
What people were trying to do is be
successful and I don't think they
necessarily equate success with happiness.
What would they do equate success with
is an alleviation of debt and alleviation
of problems and alleviation of a
lot of the issues that people face.
Hartley and they think of that as if you
look at the problems that you have when
you're growing up,
you look at the price.
Especially if you grow
up in a poor family,
one of the main problems that you face is
you're worried about paying your bills.
So you say, someday I'm going to get to
a point where that is no longer an issue.
I'm going to make it.
I'm going to be successful there.
They're not doing it thinking this
is going to make me happy. I, I've,
I've very rarely see that and which
is one of the reasons why people,
even people's parents in
this freaks me the fuck out.
We'll tell them to not
pursue their dreams,
but instead to pursue something
that's more likely to happen.
Like don't pursue your dream of becoming
an actor or a singer or whatever it is.
Instead,
pursue your dream of being the foreman
at the company you work at because that's
attainable.
I think you're totally right and there's
a lot of evidence that you're right,
that the financial anxiety is a massive
driver of depression and anxiety.
Obviously there's a interesting study
that found people who have an income from
property are 10 times less
likely to develop an anxiety
disorder that people who
don't,
and there was a really interesting
experiment in how we can respond to that.
It's when that President
Obama said late in his time,
he thinks would have to happen across
the country in the next 20 years for
various reasons. So in Canada, in
the 70s, the Canadian government,
um, chose a town at random, it
seems to genuinely have been random.
It's tackled doe fan. It's, um, anyone who
knows, uh, Kendra, it's about four hours.
I Winnepeg and they said to big
group of people in this town,
we're going to give you guys for
the net for the foreseeable future.
We're going to give all of
you a guaranteed basic income.
We're going to give you the equivalent
of, in today's money, 15,000 US dollars.
Right?
There's nothing you can do.
That means we'll take it away from you
and there's nothing you have to do in
return for it.
We're just citizens of our country.
We want you to have a good life,
right?
It was partly because they
had a kind of welfare system,
but it was a lot of people were falling
through the cracks and they wanted to do
a little experiment to see what this web,
and this was studied very carefully by
a woman name to be called Dots Evelyn
Bouygues, uh, to see what happened. It
loads of interesting things happened. Um,
people spent more time with their kids.
Very few people quit work,
but a lot of people
turns down shitty jobs.
So actual overall work standards improved
because employers have to attract
people with better
standards. Um, but for me,
the most interesting thing is there was
a huge fall in depression and anxiety,
depression and anxiety. That was so
severe. People had to be hospitalized,
fell by 9%,
which is remarkable in just three years.
And then the program ended. Dr for Jay
said to me, I thought so much about that,
that I'd learned about
the cow. Dot. Vj said, um,
you know, that's an antidepressant, right?
We should expand our idea of an
antidepressant to be anything that reduces
depression and that should include
pills, but also, so you're totally right.
I mean, look, I grew up, my dad, my dad's
a bus driver, my mom worked in a shelter,
my grandmother cleaned toilets. Financial
anxiety is a massive driver of, um,
of the despair.
This,
I mean more than half of all Americans
have not because of the incredible
financial pressure they've been put on,
the got $500 set aside for,
for crisis comes along. Right. So
you're talking about that's a huge draw.
And again, that's really
important cause explain to people,
if that's making you depressed an anxious,
don't let a doctor tell you you've just
got a chemical imbalance in your brain.
Right. That's, we'll do doctors
still say that all the time.
My nephew's best friend,
um,
just literally a couple of weeks ago
went to the doctor and was told, yeah,
you've got a dopamine and balance.
The doctor said is migrated in the 20
years since I went there from a surgeon in
England,
in England.
I mean I get contacted constantly by
people who were being told they've got
chemicals, they're told they've
got chemical imbalances.
Right.
Are they just as likely to prescribe
antidepressants in English as they are
American? I'm slightly low, but it's
still exceptionally high still. Yeah.
There's a,
that narrative that an antidepressant
must be in some sort of a pill form and
that navy, even the expression,
antidepressant and antidepressant, it's,
it's a very confusing thing that we've
sort of adopted very quickly in this
country. And it's a relatively
recent, you know, over the last 60,
70 years. And the people that
have antidepressants, uh,
in their body that take them all
the time and swear by them, boy,
if you try to tell them in,
in any way that there's a better option,
they get extremely
defensive. Um, I have friend,
she's very smart and she's,
she's one of the, um,
one of the people that,
well,
you know,
very aggressively debate this idea
that it's anything but a chemical,
depression, chemical, a
inbounds, you know, but she
doesn't take care of her body.
She's not, doesn't exercise all the time.
You know, she's slightly overweight.
She doesn't eat the best foods. You
know, it's, it's, it's a weird thing.
She's living in a society and culture
that has all these forces that are arising
that makes people feel
terrible. Right? Yeah.
And so a big thing to me is
when I'm talking to this,
because I've had some of that reaction,
well not too much,
but I've had some of that reaction
as well. First thing for me to see,
I would say I want to
expand the menu of options.
I don't want to take anything off
the table, right? It's not about,
you see that and I, and I think
you're probably being pretty honest,
but you really do want to,
you want to eliminate Mo,
but just by the standard of improvement,
you do probably want to take most people
off of antidepressants, don't you?
What need do they have a choice?
Would Jordan analogy,
obesity is massively risen
in the western world.
It hasn't risen because people
suddenly became greedy and lazy.
It's risen because our
food system is terrible.
The way feed supply system is terrible.
And we built cities that people
can't walk and bicycle around, right?
And they're really stressed all the time
and they get home from work exhausted.
So they don't have time to exercise
a lot of them in that context.
Some people will do what's the stomach
stapling, liposuction, that kind of thing.
Right now I'm not against that.
But if we change the society in the way
that I would want to with obesity so
that people could walk and cycle and you
know, they had access to healthy food,
far fewer people would need stomach
stapling or liposuction. Right.
So I would drugs,
not a perfect analogy,
but I'd say if the social changes
that I want to happen happen,
if we followed the places that
have succeeded in reducing
depression and anxiety
over time,
you would see fewer people feeling they
needed and chemical antidepressants.
Okay.